I think anymore people on this island  we're gonna sink is too many people  where a dustbin where a dustbin for  foreign people and all our resources are  pushing limits schools hospitals and  they Ches everything this is our country  so small as it is I think we should be  concentrating on our children I don't  like being controlled by someone it's  not elected  there's too many restrictions on us I  think we're losing our identity quite a  bit it's not just about immigration it's  it's about the jobs in this country we  can say who comes in how many come in  and what type of people come in I don't  like the fact that unelected bureaucrats  have got power over what goes on in this  country making rules dictated by  Brussels simple as that the English  people in this country are suffering  because of the open-door policy I  remember not being in the EU so I want  to go back to those days